so when you're recycling in amsterdam
you didn't could you go up near the red
light district
oh yeah i'll visit
i'm a big fan of porn i
i'm not trying to be in control of
anything i want to give the power up to
people who i think are more talented at
uh you know videography more talented at
photography
um
more talented i'm not going to say
another ography word
and i i deliver music like it's art like
i feel like i'm a pop artist right and
cyborg i had to use the bathroom really
really bad and they didn't give me
enough time um
i just want to tell you that
so uh
it's blended so much into what you were
talking about
but i thought you had to use the
bathroom then
i have to use the bathroom really bad
right okay well the entire interview
yeah that's okay
kanye is a producer that's how you
started the music business wasn't it
well that's because no one wanted to let
me rap because you know i didn't have
a gun on me or you know uh
and i didn't dress like and throw back
jerseys and all this and my clothes fit
and you know
the earth
uh that what what do you say the the the
sun revolved around the earth right vice
versa
you know so when you have modern but the
centristic
but this but i'm not concerned about the
specifics sir right right
[Applause]
saint vincent but it's pronounced sent
and i knew you were going to see saint
and go do you remember that we were
sending tons of names and then you wrote
back i like saint no
do not act like you don't remember that
we were sending a million names
i was supposed to work with madonna and
uh i went over a house and we were
joking about the tesla sky video and i
told her i used pamela anderson because
i i grew up on her she helped you know
make me a
champion to a man
looked like madonna was getting a little
jealous and i was like no no i used to
jack off to you too
i don't have time i'm afraid
you're that busy you can't even have a
whack
give him some time though
i can't do anything without having a
wing what's a wank exactly
just i have to do this okay you're a
sound guy just to show us what the audio
processor was he he set it up for us on
this microphone would you tell me how to
use it how
would it work if i i think if you talk
directly into it but if i
speak it doesn't really do anything
right but if i sing it'll do something
to my voice is that right
you don't care you just have to go to
the bathroom
do you feel like
your attitude towards women has changed
since having daughters
nah i still look at pornhub and
this week your cops are going to start
recruiting 16 year olds and uh take it
from me no matter how old the cops are
it's the same thing if they see a black
guy in an expensive looking car they
want to pull them over and ask them
where you got it
i am a god everybody says who does he
think he is i just told you who i
thought i was a god
i just told you that's who i think i am
kanye you're back after six years are
you happy to be back and performing
tonight much anticipated performance
with paul mccartney and rihanna i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
everything you tweet you think even have
you regretted anything that you've
tweeted nope nothing
never you don't go maybe i should have
thought about that a little longer
what's the point of thinking
50 cent has been quoted as saying that
if your album should outsell his he will
never make another album ever again have
you heard him
i really like 50. i don't want him to
retire once my album sells the most i
just wanna
i almost borderline like being sued
because it's the only time where i can
be myself because i sit in those
depositions
and it'd be hilarious i mean i was in a
deposition with suge knight and i had my
hand my hands on my face like this right
and the lawyer was sitting shook sitting
right there and sugg's lawyer sitting
next to me he said um uh can you uh
can you take your hands off your face no
i said take your hands off your face i
look down and say he said take your
hands off your face i said look sir
you're gonna have to ask me nicely to
take my hands off my face please talk to
me with some type of respect and he says
okay mr west can you please take your
hands off your face and i said
no
george bush doesn't care about black
people
in the past few days they cut right away
from him
[Applause]
he looked like what
what mike myers hurt his neck he turned
and looked like what did you just his
face is did you just say that
so famously and so powerfully said
george bush doesn't care about black
people it makes me wonder what makes you
think that donald trump does or any
people at all
why don't we take a break we'll come
back and uh kanye west right all right
kanye give us three things that are
hairy balls balls balls
the problem i have with the paparazzi is
if they're right in front of you you're
like can you please not take a picture
of me and then like dude i'm not really
taking a picture and they just keep on
doing like they're talking to me like
i'm stupid and stuff and if you're in
like with arm sprints i'm gonna like
grab the camera that just happens like
and you don't expect that to happen with
a celebrity because you think that we're
like a museum animal and stuff but it's
like don't don't shoot the animals then
maybe i don't know
[Music]
we've just recently done a new video and
you've collaborated with two massive
stars in it haven't you
yes yes i am
you're doing this thing where you're
bringing people together and you know
that's that's pretty good i think
oh you i know
name three things that get you in
trouble with your spouse
the internet
[Applause]
were you ever
concerned about her being alone in the
oval office with president trump
well he is a player
i'm with you is in the building
[Applause]
right now put your hands in the air
right now yeah where's the warrior
hoodie from my line from pastel with you
you know it looks a bit more normal when
you don't have it all the way
zipped up
that's that's just the option again
trying to like rob someone else
it'd be easy to spot later on though it
wasn't me uh
at the barber shop and everything i used
to hear like people always about man you
know when that when an entertainer get
on of course you know he gonna go and
get a white girl involving all this
but i want to say that
you know and the white girl gonna go get
a rich black dude and you know
but i want to say that my wife
has dated broke black dudes
[Applause]
everybody asked me the question they
wanted to know
what kind i know he's going well out and
he's going to do something crazy
everybody want to know what i would do
if i didn't win
i guess we'll never know
[Applause]